i'm not able to
sit here and and not comment on this
idea that
somehow this is donald trump's fault i
do not
think that the prior administration
supported legal immigration
they threw up every obstacle possible
uh to permit legal um immigration
these kids are coming here making that
kind of journey and they're not going to
be
be allowed to stay in this country 90
percent of these
children have a parent or legal guardian
in the united states
are you disappointed that president
biden and vice president harris have not
taken the time
to come to the border absolutely not
what the president and vice president
have done is directed me
to address the challenges at the border
well that was republican senators
tearing into dhs secretary
mayorkas yesterday at a hearing over the
border crisis mayorkas has repeatedly
insisted this week that
quote the border is closed
all week long our fox news cameras and
drones have been on the scene
capturing a different story with waves
of migrants crossing the rio grande
river in broad daylight
getting to the other side landing them
in the united states
one person who knows this situation
first hand he's there every day
sheriff joe frank martinez he patrols
that very section of the border in del
rio texas sheriff thanks so much for
taking time to
for us today let's ask a political
question first
here which is you heard the senators
arguing does it matter whose fault this
crisis is at this point we have a
very serious situation immigrants
without paperwork coming into this
country
are risking their lives some of them
getting sick when they arrive here
it's making the situation bad for
americans too i mean
why are we even fighting about whose
fault it is isn't it time to look for a
solution
yes i think it's time to to look for a
solution this
this problem has been going on for for
basically generations
uh you know uh one administration
passing the blame to another
administration you know that's that's
that's not acceptable
uh something has to be done to allow an
individual
a legal process to come to this country
if that's what they're looking for
so tell us you know you're used to
seeing not
videos of these scenarios but seeing
them happen right in front of your eyes
in real time what do you see when you
see these migrants
crossing the river like that is this
something that strikes you
as unusual is it something that strikes
you as
ordinary tell us like looking at these
images right now i mean it looks
incredible to those of us who aren't
used to seeing it what do you see
well this is something that has not
taken place in in this part
of our county ever
this is the first time we've experienced
something like this so it's overburdened
the our federal partners uh youth border
patrol who are doing everything they can
to handle the situation
but we see these immigrants that are
coming across fleeing and
fleeing their home country looking for a
better way of life you know you've got
to
you've got a feel for these individuals
but at the same time
there has to be a system in place that
allows them a legal process but it's uh
it's heartbreaking to watch some of
these uh family units you know dragging
their
their their small children across the
river uh you know risking their life
it is i mean there's nothing worse than
looking at this day after day we're
seeing even
small children and babies sometimes
abandoned once they get
technically to the u.s side of the
border um
so looking ahead sheriff based on your
experience
what can and should be done in the near
term
you know you're not going to solve this
overnight but at least to alleviate
a little bit of this crisis is there
anything
so you know i wish that a decision be
made one way or the other as to
to stop this because more people are
going to die
you know our state partners are involved
in
in car chases every day people are you
know there's accidents they're going
through fences and stuff
people are going to die trying to come
here so we need to put a stop to this to
this nonsense
uh until we come up with a solution
because it's only going to get worse
people are going to continue to come
uh quick last question for you sheriff
we only have a couple of seconds here
do you see any reason why this might
naturally abate over the coming months
yes or no no no all right
well thanks so much for joining us
sharing all your insight we really
appreciate getting the first hand look
at what's happening
uh have a great weekend sheriff thank
you
you all too thank you for having me